Sam and Joe Flanagan are brothers who
take mountain biking way fast extreme we
look during anything we can possibly be
on our bike the extreme it about an ally
of the better they're not too interested
in well weren't past or typical trails
it involves climbing for snow hail and
Soviet that's a good afternoon stand one
big problem with this basement and law
frosty equipment instead they hike and
bike down some of the highest snowiest
and coldest mountains its government the
kangin's
on a beautiful day can be extremely with
the reward environment in bad conditions
it can be a death Joan our childhood was
always really really active would always
be out climbing there's a lot of cave
around here in Yorkshire
both my parents were into the outdoors
so they they got into stuff like
mountain biking climbing caving from an
early age and and we just sort of fell
in love with it the cars were lived in a
rural area and mountain biking was just
the natural progression the mountain
biking we do would be classed as extreme
because of the elements that we do in
the places we do it in the kind of stuff
we're riding down it it's not your
average trail center it's steep and it's
gnarly and just an extra bit of danger
which is always a plus
Joe definitely does Kate Morris the
major he loves the climbing side of
things and that is definitely a lot more
risky if we're in a place Joel
definitely would be the first one to say
the risk
[Music]
formed 40 million years ago the
Cairngorms is a mountain range in the
Eastern Highlands of Scotland it is home
to five of the six highest mountains in
the country to say the weather is
extreme here would be an understatement
it's prone to wind speeds of over a
hundred miles per hour
temperatures well below zero and of
course the occasional Avalanche not
exactly the typical choice remounting
Viking first time I went to climb dust
with Joe shoot in the winter climb right
and it was a Laden's couloir in the
Cairngorms so that was it was definitely
a baptism of fire when we were setting
up and looking around to try and scope
in the area it was blowing an absolute
gale it was really whiteout conditions
you couldn't really tell where you were
going it's impossible to remove the
danger for a mountain biking completely
because you still out in the elements
those rocks of slippy surfaces you're
always going to have your little crashes
and you zombie the kingdoms can be on a
beautiful day can be extremely weakly
rugged environment and really beautiful
to behold but in bad conditions it can
be a Death Zone and many people have
died up in the Kingman plateau really
being caught out by bad weather or
falling off off a cliff it can be
completely another world of cold and
extreme weather on that definitely when
it's snowing actually you need to 100%
check the weather you need to make sure
that everyone's going to be safe
detailed information on what the weather
is going to be like up high what the
wind speeds are going to be like and
it's dangerous there's a lot of people
have to get rescued there's a lot of
people unfortunately are killed in the
hills around the caring homes because
they misjudged the weather
one of the main reasons of riding on the
snowy icy mountain is everything that
you've heightened everything's more
flippy everything's that little bit more
scary coming down is the best feeling
that way - really - wind blowing - you
say and carving turns in the snow it's
just for marched speed wise you on the
snow you can pick up kind of 3040 miles
now without even thinking these
stuff-your-stuff
blurry path but that's the best part a
load of adrenaline I like blending -
blending my squats and adventurous bike
in hairlike push push on I think I will
adventure until like an adventure no
more until my bhabhi allows me to to go
no further
as month good friend Craig Evans always
says death before download if you can
have to carry down it you're just going
to try it anyway just get it done see it
through
you
[Music]